so this will be like a tutorial style
talk i think so uh not not like a
one hour overview and one hour in depth
but more like a
two-hour straight tutorial is that right
actually
it's it's more or less an hour and uh
it's more or less a
yeah actually a an overview over the
field rather right i will not go that
much into d
into depth so one hour plus overview and
then we're
everybody's highly encouraged to make it
even longer with uh
you know how whatever questions we can
find
for people who are panelists they can
just unmute and speak
you can also ask questions in the chat
and i'll try to have the chat monitored
anyone who's watching this
over yeah
anyone who's watching this over the
youtube channel uh please try to join at
the
simon zoom meeting instead if you want
to ask questions
um and
attendees i think cannot speak they can
just join
they can send chat messages if you are
an attendee and want to become a
panelist so that you can speak
just send a message and we'll take care
of that
so today we have one of these clearly
beyond
sad topics we're going to learn about
answers at programming
what it is by arguably
one of the exposure d experts in the
field torsten schaub so without
who is his um uh
well uh behind
clasp which is is i think one of the
best known answers at programming
solvers and lots of
uh this is a tool that can do lots of
other things also like set solving and
pseudo boolean solving and what have you
um and um yeah so we won't spend a lot
of time on
introducing you or your wonderful c we
just want to hear you talk so please
without further ado
please okay
first of all thank you very much for the
introduction and of course also for the
invitation
so as i mentioned at the beginning uh
unfortunately my linux box
wants me to log in to with the berkeley
account it didn't work out
so i'm now back on my ipad and i have to
improvise a little bit so can you see my
mouse
highlight like this yes that's
very good okay so actually um
i i decided to i had i have a tutorial
material on this and actually
we we have our course on asp online
so if you really want to know more about
asp
i can give you the url again but it
should be easy to find
so i i decided to rather concentrate on
a on
an overview over it and be rather
shallow so some of you
may actually ask oh this is so shallow
well in this way i can cover more ground
that was more or less my motivation for
doing that
good so here is the the outline so i'll
start
by motivating the whole thing then i
give you a very crisp
overview what asp is then highlight
actually the history of it because i
think this is
interesting in particular for those of
you who have a set background and
well actually if you if you want
propositional logic goes back
in its current semantics to bool or
whatever this is such a thi such
these foundations were not available for
for asp and and for muslims alike so
it's interesting to
look where we came from then briefly
look at foundation and then actually see
how
asp can be used and then i will also
highlight in chapter six a couple of
um topics that i will not talk about
which but which i find
really interesting and then just recap i
have actually
some additional material uh on
the logical foundations because i think
this is interesting
also from a general point of view
because you can always ask the question
oh
i'm doing proposition classical logic
propositional logic first order logic
how can i make this uh non-monumental to
implement close world reasoning and
actually this
this is in the logic that that we do
this way which was actually just
discovered in the 90s right so
that's actually quite interesting even
though it traces back to
logic foundations well beyond anime
don't i don't want to deviate to it
anyway there is some additional material
here
in case i forget to mention bug me in
the question series
good so motivation first of all so
i think in in in in in sap one can say
well
the the the the big breakthrough of sat
was its applicability to computer aided
verification
and i think from my perspective and you
may you may have another perspective on
this
this had of course um quite an effect on
on on the development of satisfiability
solving
for instance that in in in the area or
mainly focuses on solving
and there's not really a modeling uh a
modeling
methodology or even a systematic
approach
uh to to to variable instantiation just
in the same way as there is a
is a clear interface to such servers
with dynamics up front and then perhaps
and then
then some also some some uh
format for the output but the other
things are missing
why why that well my belief is that in
hardware verification
you normally have modeling languages and
you just wanted to compile things down
so this didn't really didn't pop up
but this is different here with asp
because asp
grew out of is situated in knowledge
representation and reasoning and they
are modeling having a knowledge
representation language
modeling at at at a high level is very
important and let me just
go through this a little bit even though
i think this is basically
all pretty obvious so in with
traditional software and now i'm talking
about any type of software we we have
we have a user and this user wants to
solve a problem so model is a program
does problem solving
and this is then mapped on on the
computer so
what what what we have as a role here is
that of a programmer
and this programmer actually with a
program
the programmer describes this
the the pa a path to a solution
so in german we have this nice word you
know we can always compound words
like so the path to the solution this is
actually what the program does
so you really didn't do this if this
until something happens or whatever this
is what happens here
so the idea then in on on the other side
oh sorry i'm too quick here and then but
what this program describes it uh
it's it's it's an answer to the how
question how to solve my problem
and of course the dream in in in in ai
is to to go beyond that
and i now like to term this knowledge
driven software
where where the idea is you declare your
problem
but you leave actually the solution to
the computer this is a very old dream of
course which would
which goes back i think to the
beginnings of ai but i think now with
this with
with with solver technology we can
realize that this is more or less
what asp tries to do okay so in in the
what what we have rather than rather
than having
a program here a monolithic program we
have two components
we have a general purpose uh solver
which is just like a computer
just that it can in in the sense that it
can address a certain
subclass of of problems and then
actually here
the the actual problem is just specified
more or less by dumping the
the the problem knowledge and uh i think
as you as many of you know actually this
the
the scale here is not is not really
appropriate because of course the solver
has many more lines of code than
normally the problem specification has
okay so while of course the program
address
the how question here actually the we
want to address here the what question
what actually is
uh the the problem and then solve
the how questions but in a generic way
that's actually why i put here
an exclamation mark in the same way as a
computer
who can who knows how to run a program
how to execute it
the solver knows how to solve
combinatorial
search problems and the only the problem
specific part is this year with the with
the question mark
which is much smaller than here in in
the program
so this this about uh uh
the the situation and the motivation so
and also of course then roles shift
right here we have a
still a programmer here we have in the
best case an expert
who's not even a computer scientist so
who more or less expresses his knowledge
in a modeling language
and then this is given to a solver and
passed on to the machine
so what's the benefit of this well
first of all the expert an expert must
only express
uh their knowledge that's one thing and
what you can get is since it's really at
a high level of of of expressiveness
the the description of the of the code
is very transparent you can easily
you can easily modify it maintain it and
of course
reliability is also something because if
you only have to verify let's say a half
a page of logical
of logical specification this is much
easier done of course than verifying
then verifying uh imperative code
okay this is more or less these are the
benefits of this upper part here
but actually one we still dream of going
higher in the sense that
uh that we do not actually let the
expert express
their their knowledge in terms of
logical specifications but even to go
up to natural language and then actually
not
only have experts but lay persons and
this is i think is is really something
and we are not
yet there somehow in a production way
but the people are doing research on
that they are not using
plain natural language but actually
controlled natural language
where for instance if you want to to
come up with a shift planning system for
for a larger company
then you can translate this into into
into basic text
and the union then could could could
vote on that even alternative
formulations on that and this is
actually one of the
i think one of the one of the visions
actually that that the community has in
that that we really try to push it
uh up and up and up but again this
having lay persons writing things in
natural language is
doable in academia but it's not yet not
yet there for
for broader audience then of course for
the solver these are the same
here we find the same the same
advantages that we have with sat or cp
solvers right
they're general they're they are
effective they
they can prove optimality in the sense
they are complete right
and they are freely available that's
more or less the same thing as as you
have also in
other communities okay
so uh this is more or less the picture
than we are
we are faced with and again what is
really different here is
that things are driven from this idea of
doing knowledge representation
and reasoning and and this of course has
has
as leads in asp to certain design
decisions which are different
than than in in for instance in set or
even in cp
okay i'll talk a lot about it yes please
uh
i don't know if it will get us
sidetracked but i just thought if we're
going all the way to natural language
uh are we sure that the user even knows
i mean it has like a fully consistent
specification in mind i mean it might be
that they have a
you know maybe design goals that are
mutually inconsistent because they
wish for something that is too good to
be true
yes and and this is this is even even
the case right so let me
so again i'm not talking now about
really an application that started with
natural language
but even uh we we are doing shift
bending actually for swiss railway
and um and there all the all the
existing shift blends that we got
were all inconsistent
and um and and this is actually
something that the system has to cope
with identify inconsistencies so the
typical thing is just
is simply people workers are allowed to
to
to to to fix their holidays and
actually night shifts are very popular
because
they they pay more and then somehow
already by fixing these normally things
get inconsistent and then of course the
poor guy
who is normally doing the shift painting
manually he's
well the guy stands and says oh i need
this vacation i need this night [ __ ]
what should i do
then he of course bends a bit the rules
and something gets inconsistent so
even on the logical specification level
we already see these inconsistencies and
have to deal with it so
i'd say that pushing things up
to the natural language level will
not necessarily give us another quality
of inconsistency but of course it will
also be there
the thing i should also say is so at
least
the the the person who is who we're
collaborating with is ralph schweder
he's working at macquarie university in
sydney
and he's using controlled natural
language right so the idea is not that
you
write free text it's a bit the idea when
you write when you write a
um an sms on your cell phone right and
you
would only use completion so you could
not actually freely type text but you
could only more or less use
the vocabulary that the that the editor
provides to you
and this of course helps a little bit in
keeping inconsistencies low
so what's it's
you know that's a bit the thing with
with web talks right so what was my
question my answer okay
that was great yes yes yes perfect thank
you so much okay good
okay now let's let's look a little bit
more about
um what a what what what asp is about
and well it is as i said it's esp is
thought of as an approach
for declarative problem solving and i'm
really using now the term
problem solving here because i think
again this having having this this word
programming in here is really a misnomer
because at least for me programming is
something where you exercise control
and the idea of course here is that you
only pose your problem
and there's no control about you
completely decouple your specification
from the execution right and
that's of course that's actually why
programming is more that's just an
historic thing and
it's a bit unfortunate uh good so this
is what asp is
is about and where does it come from
well
one could say asp has four mothers
so i think the the the very basic form
of asp is
is databases deductive databases
then of course where really the stable
models the medicine all came from is
logic programming where people looked at
the declarative semantics for prologue
a semantics for logic programs that is
independent of an execution model
then of course knowledge representation
and reasoning and
here in particular not not not a general
reason but in particular non-monotonic
reasoning
and actually these three
parents have already one thing in common
they're all
non-monotonic they all work under the
closed world assumption
while in databases this is of course the
simplest approach where you say well
if information is not in a database
and that thus unknown you set it to
false this
information so you might have a default
value for this
and of course in logic programming this
was generalized because there is not
about non-membership
but there it's about non-derivability
with all the difficulties that
that come with it and then more or less
what satisfiability solving uh more or
less contributed
is of course the the effective solving
technology so and
and i should say this really upfront an
asp solver is not
a sat server it's not based on a satsang
so you can map asp
into into propositional logic and then
give it to a set server but
you can also map it into milt if you
want right so
but actually class for instance is a
genuinely built asp server which you can
also use as a set server
but more or less i think benjamin
kaufman the designer always keeps saying
10 of the source code of clasp more or
less cover
set functionality right the rest is
really
what you need for to cover different uh
constraints or different reasoning modes
etc etc
right okay so this is more or less the
first take-home message that you can
view asp as a
as as a combination of database
technology notably deducted database
technology which is
not only about not only about the
the close world assumption but also
the the techniques that are used to
instantiate a first order specification
with all objects of the of the heron
universe
this is done with techniques from
deductive databases
and um this comes from there then of
course logic programming
the the syntax and the and the original
ideas knowledge representation the
modeling language the reasoning modes
and uh sat as as more or less the
the parent actually that is that that
inspired the solving technology
okay so what is it good for i think you
all know that
it's a you can solve combinatorial
optimization problems with this
but i think where really the unique
selling point lies in
is in this knowledge intense um
variance of them because you can really
write the right nice specifications and
work with them
okay so what what problems are these but
this is more for for
for perhaps not such a knowledgeable
audience as you guys
so these are problems where you have a
lot of decisions to be taken
under constraints and i guess um
here's just a couple of examples and of
course all these examples you can just
as well
solve with with in in in set or or you
can solve them in
cp and so on and so forth one thing
however that
i find interesting is and and again i'm
not talking a little bit also from from
our startup perspective
of in the company so we get these echoes
that
oh i don't know actually how you came up
with this specification
but i think i can follow it i think
these are the rules of our of
of the problem that we have and this is
i think a very a
very nice feedback actually that we get
and of course our competitor out there
in the world is is not sat right it's
this
this is milk or these are systems like
cplex or gorobi or so right and they of
course you need experts who really don't
know how to code and more or less the
manager or the guys actually that
or the experts they don't really get to
know they don't get this direct
uh reflection actually on their
specification which you which you get in
that way
okay so what any industrial ones here
well here
here are some some some highlights on
on esp success stores actually those of
you who use
debian or ubuntu they may actually be
using if they have if they don't take
the standard configuration they may
actually be using clasp
and clingo for solving their limits
package configuration
um then i think the first spectacular
application of asp was done by michael
gelfand at texas tech
who used it for for decision support for
the space shuttle
and there are some other some oh
actually and this was the first spin-off
that used asp that was started at the
technical university of
helsinki now although university who who
used it for product configuration
okay one thing that i find interesting
and this is not really
um any an asp-specific application
actually there actually class was used
as a set solver
was uh the arc the the frequency auction
that happened in the us
a couple of years back that was run by a
spin-off
consulted by kevin leaton brown
and what what of course is interesting
for us
is that actually a u.s department
takes university software off the shelf
uh and of course look this is this is
quite a
a revenue that that that was at play at
that point and
um they uh they they they used it and we
actually
only learned about this uh afterwards
and
what is interesting here is so why did
they use
somehow an asp server as a sat server
one of the
of the high performance um set servers
well
the history is a bit the following so
class actually won
i don't know five six seven a couple of
times the sad competition
um mainly on the in the in the not in
the industrial not in the in the random
in in the other competition the crafted
one i don't know how it's called now
um and then actually there after and
then afterwards
we let it participate in the competition
that was run also by kevin
holger horse and marcus schneider where
the situation is a bit different where
the situation is you take your solver
and you let more or less an algorithm
configurator explore the search space
and then you take the best configuration
for this solver that you find for the
problem and then you compare these guys
and they're actually class at least the
ones we participated
one each time more or less and
interestingly i think the reason for
this is of course you know when we
started we didn't know actually which
techniques are always good which that
techniques we can use which ideas we
came up with you can use or not use
so class has thousands of well thousands
of course exaggerated right but
you need you need a pager to look at
through the help menu and you can
it's really highly configurable
and and this actually helps a lot
because if you if you take it as
as a solver and then configure it you
normally get really good
good um configurations and this is
actually how
kevin also used it here so they had they
had a portfolio
of two solvers and they then they they
built with this this one solver and
there was
a class was the complete solver and the
incomplete server was a local search
server they built at the
at ubc in vancouver so that's actually a
pretty pretty cool thing
simply because it also shows that that
that the solvers are mature enough to be
to be deemed to be tackling such
such problems good
and well even though i haven't really
introduced asp what are its
distinguishing features well one
that again we have in common with with
set solvers and and to a certain extent
cp so it's the high performance the high
performance of the solvers but what
really adds to it
is this high level versatile modeling
language
and there are actually two things come
come with it
so one is the modeling as such what what
what is a
how do you model problems what is a good
way to do that right
and then of course the modeling language
has first order variables you have to
have
in the same way as you have standardized
by input output grounders you have
a solvers you have to have grounders
that take a specification
and there is now a standard asp language
there's a standard out
since a couple of years and then they
take that guy and
also then output in the standard case a
machine readable
format similar to dynamics just of
course because it's richer
because there are also cardinality
constraints weight constraints
um optimization statements and stuff
like this but that's more or less than
the default workflow
um and what what is also built in asp
servers right from the beginning
is lexicographic multi-objective
optimization and you there are tools
actually that even can combine this with
qualitative and quantitative
optimization
you can do i don't know you can form
expressions that describe a preference
criteria like you
the pareto of i don't know uh the mini
minimization of of of the route
maximization of
of the fun and so on and so on and you
can express preferences also in a
symbolic way for instance like saying
oh if i have fish then i prefer white
wine to red wine without without ever
attributing a number to these guys so
that's actually i think one of the
one of the nice things and again
motivated from the heritage from
knowledge representation and reason you
want to have this flexibility in
modeling
okay then well industrial impact as
mentioned so we have a spin of
uh protasco solutions that we are
running there's all actually there was
even one
there was this variant which i mentioned
before in helsinki and then
this is the other one that is existing
it's dlv which is running
running in in calabria um
and yeah so i i think we are doing
pretty good
because even though people always wonder
a little bit there's a logical
specification and you push the button
and get something out so that's actually
still a
bit of a mystery not to mention that
and you face this too every day that we
have to explain then that we're not
doing machine learning and
when you then hear the question what is
the depth of the neural network well
but now we are used to that okay good so
that was the nudge let's look a little
bit at the history of it and to get a
bit of a feeling what actually the
issues
were in coming up with with asp as it
stands right now
so again this is a very biased view of
course by by myself right
so um so i started with
looking at this actually in the 80s well
actually 88 or so i think i got got
involved in normal sonic reasoning
default logic and all this type of stuff
but of course
one could trace things back of course to
to
to mccarthy and haze the frame problem
how to do things but well i'm not
i'm not a deviant i'm not delving into
that anyway in the 80s i think there was
there were the first attempts of really
in capturing incomplete information
then in the 90s i think people wanted to
there was of course a whole zoo of
different semantics around how to put
them together and how to compute things
then we had the in the beginning of of
the millennium we had the
first application and and i think this
is interesting for you guys
semantic rediscoveries because as i
mentioned
uh when you look at sat right all this
all these
all these the theoretical backbone like
i don't know proof complexity
um semantic issues and so on they really
look back on
on heaps of work on on decades
and centuries of of of of
mathematical and and theoretical
investigations
this wasn't the case here that's
actually why we were faced with such a
result
zoo at the beginning because there was
this phenomenon which is actually i
would say very natural
in databases we experience it every day
but how to capture it it was just
actually at the end of the of the
millennium when someone proposed
but when really the breakthrough and
then of course nowadays
it's that's again it's so funny it's
it's the same everywhere right in the
same
way such started out and at some point
theories had to be had to be integrated
that's actually the same thing as that
that happened in you know automated
theory improving right they were
automated
at some point they needed theories and
of course the same thing
also happened in in asp these days okay
let's detail this a little bit so in the
80s
there were there was the field of
databases where actually keith clark
published this seminal paper in 78 how
to capture
uh close world reasoning by actually
viewing viewing tables as
sufficient conditions and then actually
adding the necessary conditions more or
less turning an implication into
into an into an equivalence and to
capture close world reasoning databases
and in logic programming and the
interesting thing is if you look
if you look at the data structures
within class
you will actually find these this
completion of of clark of this of this
day
of these days then in logic programming
of course negation of failure was the
big thingy
and again the the now actually my
my um just a sec i have to charge my pen
again on
at the same time because since i was not
prepared to give it on the ipad
okay so then of course negation has
failure
that more or less that you can derive a
negative literal
by a finitely finitely uh
terminating failure of a derivation
right
that was that was more or less what what
what was happening there and then of
course there's non-maturity reasoning
where
really different semantic approaches to
to handling negation or defaults also
come up other epistemic logic by
by moore right where the idea was oh i
do
a self-reflection about my knowledge the
idea is well
i don't have an elder brother because if
i had one
i would know it that was a bit the idea
how to do close world reasoning
or default logics by writer where you
explicitly add additional inference
rules
second scription by mccarthy where the
idea is that you have certain predicates
which
denote abnormalities and you want to
minimize them so your reason will spit
to minimal models right
but this was all very
well as i said i think at the time
people may have called it esoteric but
you really had to capture a phenomenon
and this very different mathematical
tools more or less where were
uh applied of course in normal reasoning
the real difficulty came from the fact
that people wanted to use first order
logic and do not like reasoning with
first order logic well
you can imagine that everything that
really happened on first order it got
undecidable okay then
uh amalgation computation well the
interesting thing is
uh at some point all this zoom oil has
collapsed
and what is interesting is that that
actually it were the semantics from
non-monotonic reasoning
that led to the canonical ways of
of of of logic programming semantics so
actually stable model semantics as such
was
that the definition of stable semantic
as such was first published by two
french women
christine francois and nicole biedwar
and they actually derived this
the semantics of stable modern semantics
from default logic while
vladimir lipschitz and michael gelston
published their paper
later uh but of course they're very
reactive and they are more or less
looked at at the fathers of stable
models and this but
historically it's one just looks at the
date it's actually two french women
who actually derived it from other
epistemic reasoning and what is
i think more astonishing vladimir told
me the other day
that at the same time there was in
philosophy they also
proposed but i forgot the name
unfortunately but
but there's yet another completely
independent proposal of the same
semantics at the time
and so more or less what what what well
found it's because when you talked about
stable modern wealth and semantics is
their relation is very nicely described
in the second bullet where
if you think of computation you compute
the stable models
by propagating through well-founded
semantics because well-founded symmetric
is is propositional and then your branch
this is actually
the original title of a paper by via
subramanian at the time
who described that okay so more or less
then again we came we had this big
zoo of different semantics and they all
more or less
uh converged to to well-founded stable
models that makes very well found it was
more or less the propagation the
the characterization of the propagation
strength of a solver
well application well we've we've
i've shown you some applications on the
last slide so there's not so much to be
said about now but what i find so
interesting is this
is this the rediscovery of what actually
there's the the logical foundations of
this kit because keep in mind everything
that happened up here
everything happened up here you took
more or less classical logic
propositional first order and you did
something with it
right fixed point constructions redux or
whatever
but it was actually in in in the 90s
that
that david pierce discovered that logics
that were
that were uh studied by
uh heightened and girdle so heightens
logic is the logic of here and there
this is actually
this is a cryptkey structure with two
worlds which which is an intermediate
logic so
it contains the tautologies of
intuitionistic logic but an is more or
less the
strongest intermediate logic so once you
add something you get to classical logic
this can be seen as the monotonic
foundations of this and at the same time
this logic is equivalent
to the logic g3 of girdle
and when you do minimization on both of
these monotonic logics
you exactly end up with stable model
semantics and actually once this was
discovered and i had to
i have to admit it also took me a couple
of years to really realize how important
this was
you can now very easily design
new knowledge representation languages
uh by combining logics
so so what we for instance do now we
have a
a a version of of
of our solver that treats linear
temporal
operators and dynamic logic operators
and you can very nicely build this up by
from first principles you you put the
logic you put it together
then you you delineate the logic
programming factor and then you have a
semantics you can think about
application
uh implementation of it so anyway as i
said
i have some slides on that afterwards if
you're really interesting because this
is one thing
that that that keeps fascinating with me
since a couple of years
and then yet as i said integration is
now the big thingy because you want to
put this in practice
yeah okay foundations
so now i do something that i hope you
it's not too oversimplified but i can go
over
and go through this a bit more quicker
let's look at actually what this
at some semantic issue what this all
means so this is more or less
a logic programming rule you have a head
and a b and c
are atoms and you we have here the
negation in the in the body
and the comma here is a is a conjunction
and yeah that's it
and one way to view a set of such rules
is like a normal form like a conjunctive
normal form
because uh spoiler ahead right so for
instance the decision problem on on such
programs here is is mp complete but
actually when if you have a proper an
arbitrarily nested propositional formula
and you want to determine the stable
model
this goes to the second level of the
polynomial hierarchy
okay now let's get a ceiling for that so
the semantics
is then given by associating stable
models with a program
and these are actually classical models
where this is of course
in quotes here where each atom that is
true in
in such a stable model must be justified
and justification is not means more or
less
there is uh a sequence of rules
where more is you apply forward training
modus ponens right
where you took actually the implication
in the literal way
and actually in the logics i was
describing before implication is a
primitive collective
and then you derive more everything that
is true in a model must have a
derivation from the fact by uh
by our implications okay let's let's
look a little bit more into that
so i'm simplifying this here and this
works for normal logic programs but not
in general so just keep this in mind
so i think i think everything we all
know from our undergraduate dates is
truth tabling this is more or less if
we now want to look at propositional
logic and i i just
use now set as a synonym for
propositional logic under
under classical semantics we have here
our
our interpretation that we want to
evaluate the formula to determine
which of the interpretations are the mod
so what we do is
we take the truth values that you have
on the left hand side we copy them in
here
and then we apply more or less the
logical rules to simplify that right so
we
evaluate negation we evaluate
implication
we we then simplify it accordingly then
this goes on here
here the ones that are true and we we do
this until
we have finally evaluate completely
evaluate the formula
and wherever the formula was evaluated
to true
these four guys here these are the
models
okay but actually what we don't do we
we we guess more actually here there is
no guess because we go
through all the through all the
interpretations but whenever we have
such
interpretation here we never ask
ourselves or is there any reason why
b is b and c are true
after all this is just an assumption you
you start with assumptions
and then you look actually how how
things work out
okay i'm saying this of course in that
way because in asp the idea is to do
this a bit differently
so yeah so i'm oh i forgot this so we of
course i'm using here a lot these
set notations here for models so these
these four guys here i will just denote
by there by this
by the set of the of the entailed atoms
so let's do the same thing in asp now
truth table so what you do is also you
put actually these the truth values of
the atoms
into the formula but only whenever
something is preceded by a negation
so that's what we get so we see here
here b is the only
sub formula preceded explicitly by
negation and again this now works nicely
with the normal logic programs
one has to do a bit more effort in the
general case so only b
is replaced and then you just evaluate
you you more or less simplify simplify
simplify
until you actually end up with what is
called the reduct and this is a
these are just definite clauses or
clauses that do not contain any negation
anymore
okay now what now that we have this
redux
the idea is actually to take this and to
see whether our assumption that we
that we did like that b is true and c is
true
can be justified is there a proof for
that
and that's more or less than so we look
at the four models and
so here actually we of course since we
have since we have definite uh clauses
there's always a smallest model and and
we just have to look into this guy so
here
from this guy no atom we cannot derive
any
i'm just looking at atoms now so we
cannot derive a b
c so but here actually here we can
derive a
and here as well but it turns out that
for instance here c
cannot be derived and then we can check
actually whether
whenever we assume that something was
true
can we actually reproduce this via a
proof
and this is now given here in red so
whenever there is something in that we
we will not get a proof
in that way so we assumed a proposition
to be true
but in the end we cannot prove it at
least in
if we understand a proof as a derivation
from facts over
implications right the only model
actually that
where we can we can we can find a proof
for all
the the atoms we assume to be true is
this one and this is actually
uh and we can do the same thing for all
the interpretation but there's nothing
to
speak this is actually here the only
stable model
and this is actually what what happens
in in when when in the original
definition of of of california lift
shifts right
you you you want us to do a similar
thing that you're doing classical logic
with truth tables
it's just that you stuck you you you you
stop at positive format then you use
this reduct
uh to check actually whether you can
really prove something that you only
assume to be true
okay so we get only one stable model
here which
contains a
good yeah so in a way the stable models
are the smallest models and there's
always a unique smaller
smallest model of each of each reduct in
the case of normal logic problems
so this was more or less in a very
simple a simple way to describe the
original reader you can
there is actually a paper by vladimir
lipschitz which keeps changing its
titles
i think now the title is 13 definitions
of stable model semantics
there may be it may meanwhile be more
than than that
and he started out with much less but
here's actually here's
the relation perhaps nailed down so what
you
if you use asp and you and
you want to get sat out of it so again
that
stands just first for the propositional
logic under classical
under classical semantics you simply add
the laws of the excluded middle
that is for each proposition an a or
not a to it because this is exactly the
axiom that
goes from this intermediate logic into
classical logic that takes you there
so this is more is what you have to do
if you want to encode sat
in asp you simply you write things down
as an asp specification and you add
the laws of these two middle and
actually the syntax of this in the
program is
so if you want to express a or not a
this is expressed as a choice rule which
is just a set
like this on the other hand if you want
to encode
asp in set you have to do some heavy
lifting
so you have to add what is called
completion and loop formulas
now completion formulas are completion
formulas uh
are actually what clark invented it's
more or less the
you you your the program gives you the
sufficient condition and you add the
negative
the necessary condition you turn
implications into equivalence
but this does not forbid infinite proofs
like if you have a program p
if p if you do the completion of this
you
you turn the if into an if and only so
you have p
if and only if p but there's still this
somehow this
infinite derivation which is still there
and you get two models of this
this is why you need loop formulas
and these guys are bad
in the way that uh these loop formulas
again you you look at the at the defense
at the dependency graph and you look at
all the strongly connected components
and then maybe in the end an exponential
number because there's no minimality
criterion on them so there may be an
exponential number of loop formulas
this actually means that if you
translate
asp into set over the same language so
without doing exciting translation
without auxiliary atoms
so over the same language you risk an
exponential blow-up because you may want
to have to add exponentially many loop
formulas
while if you encode a set in asp well
this is just you just add at the extreme
middle there's no
so it's a constant overhead right
um so this is actually one thing and now
you may ask oh
this gets more complex well of course
both are both decision problems at least
for prog
rules and c and f are in the same class
so there is of course a translation with
auxiliary atoms
but where does it you may ask where does
this show and in fact it shows and i'll
give you an example later on because
things like of course defaults can be
very trivially encoded because it's not
monotonic
but also reachability reachability can
be natural
just encoded in in a standard
understanding we will see this in a
second
okay good so this was all about asp
viewed as normal logic programs but keep
in mind if you want to check
a propositional formula and you really
go one level higher
if you if you this is the price that you
have to pay
for close world reason but what is nice
again
yes can you say anything about like this
when you evaluated your formula what was
the reason for only
substituting values for negated the
axioms and then propagating
like how i didn't get it i guess what's
happening
my suggestion this is actually the the
definition of a stable model is actually
is so you do a reduct you have a program
you do a redux
with your guess and then you calculate
the smallest model of this
and this is and if the original guess if
you solve this fix this is more like the
criteria right
this was more or less translating this
into the
into into into truth tables so my
suggestion is
uh and the guest just the clever the
guests are like you care about the atoms
we set to
true those are the ones yes yes
but my suggestion is let's postpone this
question and i can show you actually the
the this logic of here and there in the
end because this is actually interesting
to look at
okay good so
um here we are now let's actually see
how
what you can do with asp right again i'm
this is not very deep but at least we
cover a lot of ground in that way and
that was
is more or less my intention um so this
is more or less the workflow
that that you have in asp so of course
what you want to do is you want to get
go from a problem to a solution but the
first thing is you model your problem
and again this program thing is a
misnomer because it's
it's there's no program there is a
specification and the
order doesn't matter and all that type
of thing so it really you model
you model your your problem and then
this is a first order specification with
this first order variable and so on and
so forth then you have
here a system that is called grounder
and this grounder
is replacing all first order variables
in a systematic way with the elements of
the herband universe
this grounder already takes the
semantics into account
so for instance if there is a rule
if you have an atom if you have an atom
that does
not occur in any head in any uh
conclusion of a consequent of a rule you
can set this atom to false because
it will never be derivable and such
things can be done in a cascading way
and this helps but of course in the
worst case um
actually grounders are and now this is a
bit of a funny fact
grounders have function symbols and
hence they are turing complete
so you can encode turing machines in in
just this grounding step
okay so what you then get here at that
point is a propositional representation
of your
program and actually here the internal
format you can think of this as dynamics
just a richer form
right and then you have the solver and
this solver
spits out the stable models but actually
it can do more things right
on top of the stable mode and of course
you interpret this
okay so yeah so i was i could have done
this a bit
more animated but yeah sorry for that
i was still a bit with the last question
so so once you have done that actually
one thing that is is particularly nice
i find about asp is because once you see
your stable model and you see ah there's
a bug
or so there's something that is not
right it's a very short distance to
elaborate this and to go back
to the specification because again
talking about
a set right so what more or less you you
do in set
is you have to write a program that
takes the problem
and maps it here so it's not that you
have a modeling language it's not that
you have
a a general purpose grounder for things
and that's of course the nice thing
because you just keep from your stable
models you can go back to the modeling
language
modify your representation and you don't
have to delve in
to the code of a python program or c
program or whatever
that produces the dynamics format for
you you know it's one thing that you
have written
this thing but some if someone else has
written this and you have to to go in so
it's not really elaborate what we call
elaboration tolerance that's actually
one of the
i think one of the unique selling points
of asp that there is a modeling language
and a general purpose uh grounder to to
translate this into a propositional
format
and keep in mind again i think
i think if you really found the super
encoding and that's the one well why not
do this effectively because of course
this is a general purpose thing if you
know exactly what
what this this is the very best encoding
of course do that
but for teaching for for elaborating
actually i mentioned before the encoding
for debian and
and for debian and ubuntu software
configuration that we did
we did a lot of modeling effort but at
the end we had i think
almost a dozen different encodings and
we couldn't tell them apart so we had to
run benchmarks
and change them do things right and
doing this on a high level is so much
more effective and
uh than than going in doing this in
in a in an imperative program that's
that's
one of the big differences and again you
can write set
formulas just by writing the asp code
and adding the excluded middle of the
choice room then you have set some then
you have propositional logic semantics
there's actually nothing nothing to be
uh to be lost there you just have more
convenience
okay here's here are the language
constructs so first of all
you you have a a logical format you have
practical symbols and
objects everything is terminated by a
dot
and then you have first order rules here
where everything with a with a with a
another case letter is regarded as as a
variable this is then
negation here and then of course what
happens is these variables are
instantiated
by by the constants here we only have 42
so this gets replaced by the ground
so what else is there so first of all
what
is very handy when modeling are
conditional literals
logically you can view them as a nested
implication
but actually what they do is uh this is
the body so the
the the connector here is a conjunction
so you will get the conjunction
of all q of x whenever there is a
wherever there is an r of x
so for instance if you have facts r of
one
r of two r of three then afterwards this
rule will be expanded to p
if q of one and q of two and q of three
that's a type of quantification so if
you do not know actually
uh which objects will satisfy r but you
want to collect all of them
and that in form of of cure so then you
can write this at the modeling phase
without giving the full incentive or
thinking about that that actually comes
pretty comes in pretty handy
one way to that's what i forgot one way
to view this is
and you all know that is you can you can
think about this as a set right
and then this is actually the set of all
q of x such that r of x holds just that
here
once you you compute from this
intentional uh
description the extensional uh
description
it is put into a conjunction that's more
or less the the the feature of this
oops oh i'm sorry the the
the feature of this modeling console and
again it comes in very handy when you
when you
are a bit more experienced and q of x
and r of x we should think of them as
like
first order logic like prediction yes
yes yes exactly
and p and p of x are different
like they're yes yes actually you you
are allowed to to have
so a predicate is
is a symbol associated with an arity
so the the the the the the the sim
the predicate uh p with arity
zero is different from the predicate p
with rt one
okay so this guy and this guy are
different
okay
implicitly all these rules are all
quantified
but and of course there can be more
variables but keep in mind we are
so we may have an infinite we may have
an infinite
herbal universe but the grounding only
terminates if it is able to find a
finite
grounding right
and this can be either be achieved by
modeling
but that do or actually that the the
the ground has some techniques to find
finite representation of infinite ones
because
let me come let me let me come back to
that at the end of the slide actually
that's because
that's actually an interesting point
because we have to the semantics of
um so for instance
vic what is the semantics of the
grounder
uh what does it do what is because in
the end if
you if you input as i said the guy is
turing complete
and um if you have function symbols
like the integers or real function
symbols uh you
you you end up with situations actually
that you create infinite object and the
semantics actually of the ground
is described by an infinitary logic
and i can show you this now in a sec uh
with the constructs
but we first have to go i'll i'll stack
this and i'll pop the stack once point
upon some
through with it another con another
connective is um its disjunction so in
the same way as
as in the again think of it as a normal
form right
uh as in the in the body you have
the the conjunction as as the as the
primary conductive and the head you have
the disjunction this is the semicolon
however this disjunction here is neither
inclusive
nor exclusive it is minimized
and this is actually so when you when
you when you
now not have normal logic problems when
you allow this then you jump also to the
second level of the polynomial hierarchy
due due to the disju to the minimization
on the disjunction
okay a very popular construct in in in
modeling our integrity constraints and
we will see them
afterwards again this is this this more
or less you can be seen as
an implication that that entails
falsehood right
which says it must not be the case that
there is an x for which q of x
and p of x hold people
when they see this the first time have a
bit of a problem because if you want to
say that
something has to hold you have to
formulate this in a negative way
but you get used to it then here choice
you want to make choices we want to say
okay
if i have if i pick a y for which r
holds
then and then i look at all the x's for
which q hold and then i get a set
of instances of p of x y i should
i have to make at least two and at most
seven of them true
cardinality constraint the same thing
works with aggregates right you can then
write this a bit differently actually
this is is more or less a shortcut
but here you can have a sum constraint
and you can then here collect
terms and and for all the integers that
you collect here
you will take the sum and the sum should
also be between two and seven
okay now here's the point where we can
talk about uh
infinite infinite cons infinite
expressions
because if you have function symbols or
whatever right then it may well be that
here this set or also this set here is
infinite
and then the question is can one find a
finite representation of sometimes
it doesn't it one can't but
the grounder normally is pretty good at
at analyzing this and finding out
actually whether there is a finite
representation
and again what helps a lot here in the
evaluation is
closed world uh close world reasoning
having the semantics in mind because
if you know uh well let's let's say here
the x ranges over
over all integers but if you know that
in your program you can only derive
q of x for one two and three
and the others are not derivable then
you can imply a simplification saying
well even though in principle
there are my herbert universe contains
an infinite number of instances here
my semantics says that i can't derive
them hence i can simplify them away then
you can reduce an infinite
expression to a finite one so just to
make because i think this is an
interesting theoretical
thing to look at okay then this is more
or less the length these are the basic
language constructs
then you have there's also optimization
so there are two ways to express
actually multi-objective optimization
one is simply to
to use something like integrity
constraints
just that you weaken this by saying by
replacing the minus here through a
tilde which is a weak constraint which
says well if
q of x and p of x c holds then you this
gives you a penalty of c
and then you can also add somehow
something like a level
because there's there's this the
multi-objective optimization he works in
the lexicographic way right and
and more or less the higher the level
the higher the price the higher the
the the priority of it
and again now i have to charge my my
stick and this is these are weaker that
you can express
in this way reconstraints and you can
have several of them and in the same way
you can bundle them together in one
objective function
and write just minimize and this is more
or less the same
the expression the reconstraints above
is is roughly equivalent to the minimize
statement below
right so this and this are two
unfortunate yeah but yeah my
once my stick is loaded again i'll come
back to that
good so but can we keep in mind these
are meta statements right
because they talk about the program
right well while
from facts to aggregate these are really
the objects in the language
okay uh so let's look at an example a
traveling sales person
why am i choosing that because it has
these two features first of all
reachability and optimization
in one in one example so this is more or
less the problem instance you can write
down a problem you say the start
node is a then you have four cities a to
a to d
and you have roads among them and they
have a
they have they are annotated with the
weight which which stands for the
distance
okay now let's look at the encoding of
this
so the the first the first rule
says actually whenever i have a road i
can decide to travel on this or not keep
in mind
such a choice right so opening brace
closing brace stands for law of the
extruded middle either i
make this true or i make this false i
treat this then more than as
in classical logic i can choose true or
false
this this actually gives me now my
solution candidate
that's with the idea right the this very
first rule
from a from a from a methodological
point of view this is your generator
right there you generate all types of
solution candidates
and then you test it in the rest so the
two next predicates visited
let's see how good my stick is now yeah
that's it works again
um so this more or less it takes it
analyzes what
the guess that we have the guest that we
have done here
and it it checks what can we actually
visit from
from our from our guess starting at the
start
right so we start at x and we we guessed
that we travel from x to y then y is
visited that's more than the base case
and here's the recursive case so if you
have shown that x is visited
and we decided to travel from x to y
then why is this two
and now we've analyzed our our guess
and now we want to make sure that there
is no
city that has not been visited because
this means more or less that
we really went to all the cities right
so we analyze the gas and then in the
end we
we make sure that no no city is visited
twice so we look at all the
outgoing for each city we look at all
the outgoing edges
and we want to make sure that it's not
the case again that's an integrity
constraint
that it's not the case that two or more
that there are two or more outgoing
edges
and the last one is not d but it's
actually pretty effective it's just the
same thing
for the in-going edges and that's the
traveling say that's actually no
that's not the travelling that's the
hamiltonian cycle problem
and now to turn this into a traveling
sales person we add
the objective function and here i used
an an um
a weak constraint which says i pay a
panel whenever i travel
whenever i travel on when i on road x y
i pay a penalty of d
so and this is this this and adds
optimization to it and then so
so i this way i can describe the travel
in salesperson problem
so yeah i think this this is nice
because it it's first of all
keep in mind that whenever we want
variables
to to be flexible in their truth value
to be free to select the truth value we
have to allow that
because otherwise close world assumption
kicks in and if you leave things
undefined
they are set to false this is different
from propositional logic right
so this is what we do here where we use
again this is the law of the extruded
middle for all these guys where we say
oh
if for each road you can decide or not
to travel on it and this
gives you all the possibilities so the
guess is then restricted
in this case to this guy here and then
from a methodological point of view this
is the guesser
this is the checker and this is if you
like the optimizer or whatever and
that's of course the instance
that's how you write down esp programs
and
yeah and keep in mind so what you
writing the c
and f is is really trivial you take all
the variables you put them into
into these as choices logics to the
middle and then your
your your your clauses in c and f you
just put here as in
as integrity concerns and you have
written down your cns and and
which is treated under classical
propositional semantics
good so uh yeah so now if i put this in
as good practice here as well you have
an instance file and you have
an encoding file and the encoding should
of course work for all the instances
now if you launch this i i now hear
uh called clingo and klingel
is the combination of gringo the
grounder and class
the solver and this will do the
grounding and the solving
at at the same time and so what what you
see you get a first up
actually why don't that do this here
with red so you get a first answer here
and this is uh here are the atoms of
this answer
because of course you have symbols and
that's why the output i omitted some of
the guys here
this has a has an objective value of 100
then this is just branch and bound
optimization
it tries to find a
strictly better one so this constraint
is added and it finds one this is then
the second answer here
these are the real this is the better
one then again it tries to find a better
one
but that that fails and hence we know
that the last
at the last model was the best one
actually the default option is branch
and bound but clasp
also does unsatisfiable core base
optimization and combinations and so on
and so forth
good so um
so the other thing i wanted to mention
is uh in asp again it's about knowledge
representation and reasoning so it's not
just about satisfiability testing
you also want to do other type you want
to enumerate models
one thing that actually was was pretty
clear to us from our
again from the from the kr perspective
is you wanted to have projective
enumeration so you wanted to enumerate
the models but only relative to a part
of the alphabet
and and also then of course avoid
redundancies in that and
actually i think class was or is or was
one of the first solvers who had
a cdnl algorithm tuned to enumerative
projection
and which actually worked without
solution recording not to say that
solution recording is sometimes pretty
good
but it it has this option then one thing
that is also
a very nice which which we like a lot to
approximate our answers you can compute
the intersection and the union of the
model that's also one f
one one uh functionality and of course
you can do optimization and combinations
of them
within bioinformatics uh actually
our bio biological persons were always a
bit
stunned when this when you describe the
biological organism then you get i don't
know hundred thousand models
well which one is now the real one they
asked at least here
with the intersection and the union we
can say well what is true in all the
optimal models right or what is
what is not true in the union of all the
one
this way you can at least give an upper
and the lower bound of things that must
be
true or must be false
good so this is the architecture of
class just is multi-threaded you can go
up to 64
cores if you like but i would not
recommend this
so let me just briefly go a little bit
through this so you you start with a
logic problem
and then you have two phases of
pre-processing the first one is actually
on the logic problem so you more or less
do
simplifications uh knowing that you have
a logic program in your hands
and then you uh then and on the close
close world reason then you translate
actually the logic program
into what we call no goods but you can
see this as charges right
and then you apply uh also
pre-processing that is inspired from
techniques in set but normally you
cannot apply a single technique just off
the shelf
simply because of close world reasoning
you have to think this through and
modify it and you have to keep more
information around
because also for for for the proofs
right
then actually what you have in clasp and
this may be a bit old-fashioned but for
asp problems this is really nice because
asp problems consist let's say over a
row of some
seventy eighty percent of binary clauses
and there are also some ternary ones
that's actually why
we have special data such as one of the
first set servers
for short clauses for binary and ternary
clauses
and they are also shared among all the
threats
then one is you can you can see actually
a solver is
pretty much following the the basic uh
the basic
um um cdcl
algorithm just of course that you have
to that you have to uh
you have to have actually we implement
this as propagators that account for
these additional formulas in particular
for the loop formulas because
you cannot uncomp compile them out
because this will give you an
exponential blow up so you have to have
a lazy propagator that spits them out if
needed so one way to
look actually at an asp server here at
this level here
is like an smt solver so more or less
you have a set solver
and the theory is asp specific one way
to
to do that another thing that is very
typical
uh is this enumerator thingy that's
for the reasoning modes because this is
the guy that always tells the solver if
he found the model
what to do next so if you are optimizing
this enumerator will know oh i'm in
i'm optimizing so uh thanks for the
model this is here's a new constraint so
the one that you have to find a better
model now
then the solver goes on and so on so
forth right
okay so this is a very rough overview
over this but again keep in mind what i
was saying at the beginning
uh benjamin keeps saying that 10 of of
clasps
code would would give you a set solver
so there's much more you have to do
in order to to make it an asp solver
yes and okay so i'm almost at the end
let me talk about omissions what
what didn't i talk about what i find
interesting one thing that i
really like is meta programming and um
what since you have a syntax what you
can do is you can actually describe your
own
asp solver as an asp program
and then do modifications to it right so
this is again
i don't know for each language contract
you have a rule and then if you want to
reinterpret
one of the constructs you just write
this in asp you can do meta programming
that you can also then
uh compute other things and and so on so
forth
quality and quantitative optimization
are already talked about right
so you can you can also have qualitative
preference and combine them with
quantitative preference and have
arbitrarily nested expressions that that
then actually are then taken into
account when optimizing
so then and then the the this one
actually i also like a lot this was
actually inspired
by a worker of you see winter you may
remember uc for time was working
very strongly on on set planning
and he tried to look into the planning
techniques
and integrate them into a set solver and
i thought this is a great idea just in
asp the idea is
that you do not integrate this hardwire
this in the solver
you put it out to the user
so that he can actually have that there
are language statements that then
actually provoke this action
and heuristic programming comes from
that so what you can actually do is
you can write almost like a rule where
you say oh
i will this atom here this like in the
head of the rule
uh will be biased when you do visit so
when you do berkman or whatever buy
an additive or a multiplicative factor
or you have
you have the layers to choose from and
actually
uh that in for planning actually for
planning when there is a plan
this allows you to speed planning up by
orders of magnitude
i think in the paper we reported two or
two hours of magnitude of course when
the thing is unsatisfiable
these heuristics are not so nice or when
you want to do optimization
so a very very robust way to
to to to to boost the conversions to an
optimum
is by when you have a minimize statement
to
to to to work on the sign used to say
look these atoms that are in the
minimize statement
preferably assign them the value
false or preferably assign them first
right and these are again uh just in
case whenever
whenever the the choice is made in the
solver these things are looked at
there's no propagation nothing else
happening and that's actually a pretty
nice thing because you give it to the
user you can write it down you can
you can you can specify it in in his
in his in his encoding on the first
order
okay then the last two thing is uh i
think it's also
it's more as engineering theory solving
is of course that if you want
to include uh foreign theories and
document the inference and solve it just
like submodular theories
multi-shot solving is a bit like
incremental solving but it's i would say
a bit broader
where the idea is what multi-shot
solving gives you you can
launch solver objects and then talk to
them right you can add information
retract the information change the
configuration of the solver on the fly
or get a model analyze it feed something
back so once you
the solver is an object with which you
you can interact
and what we were doing recently we were
actually augmenting asp with
with linear temporal and dynamic
reasoning
uh actually to to tackle temporal
problems
one thing i didn't talk about we also
have have
notably here in the in the theory
solving part
you know of course the the first
integrations that that
we also did when when when pairing asp
was with with with constraint processing
systems like we
we we use g code at the time right but
then you look at your system and then
after a while you say oh it's great but
it's a bit of talk right because what
you do is
you have really this you have this
non-monotonic reasoner this close word
reason the asp which really
where the semantics has
well has something to say then you plug
in a reason that is monotonic
so what it's you immediately you had the
dilemma
if you have how do you assign a default
to constraint variable well you can't
because
either you model the variable in asp
this means oh you can assign a default
value but how will you handle
integer values well grounding will kill
you well if you then model it as a
constraint variable
great you can handle the integer domain
but you cannot handle the
uh you cannot modulate it as a default
right because you just plug
together two systems but you and it was
nice but it
it was not really semantically coherent
and actually what we
are doing now we are looking at
semantics for such
systems that actually allow you to cover
the whole the whole combination under
one semantics and also actually then
have
have arbitrary theory um
solvers and then give them a normal
chronic semantics for instance and we do
this with denotational
semantics because of course we wanted to
stay general enough that we don't have
to talk about
theories and we have this implemented
which i found pretty cool
actually sorry i'm i'm bubbling but in
our company actually
the solver that we use most is actually
an extension of clingo with different
constraints this works like
this works like a charm and covers so
many applications out there
okay anyway if you feel playful just
just visit
our github site which has just the name
for tesco
and there you can find i think over 100
implementations and systems drafts and
and so on you can just have fun with
them
good then let me recap the take home
messages
so first of all asp is a modeling
grounding and solving paradigm
and actually if you look for instance in
our papers on extending extending it
with modulo theories
it's not enough that you use smt server
no no no solving is not enough you have
to think about grounding you have to
think about modeling
actually what lingo gives you is a
grammar formalism in which you can then
actually write
a grammar to describe the new language
elements and then the ground i will
respect you can model them with this on
the ground i will respect it and give it
give it to the solver and of course from
a
technological point of view asp is a
combination of deductive database
techniques logic programming knowledge
representation reasoning and
and sat as a representative
representative of cdcl
and if one is very exact one you can
actually look at this as a
as an smt uh as an smt search procedure
where you have several theories for
instance you have the theory of course
that gives you the semantics of asp
close world reasoning and optimization
this would already make two of them
good and and again if you've if you were
more interested more in that we have
this site protasker.org so potassium
stands for the potassium solving
collection
and and now actually unfortunately now
my stick left me there is
this teaching.org gives you a
full-fledged master course
on asp with videos jupiter notebooks and
all these type of things so
this was is one of the positive positive
corona effects
and now to wrap up uh yeah and it's fun
of course to wrap up
uh after all it's all about tweety and
this was actually an idea
when that came came to me when um
when i gave an invited talk at the sat
conference at bordeaux at the time
so this was actually i don't know
whether you remember these readings
in that that were in ai at the end of
the 80s beginning of the 90s and that of
course this was sitting on my desk all
the readings are normal
greasing how can you more or less equip
this little penguin so that it flies
and then i think thanks to to to set
technology
we now have this little guy here um
well where were more is equipped now
tweety with uh with
uh with rocket engines but taming the
guy is is still something
okay good so this ends actually my talk
and uh actually i don't know how was i
well not so bad
perhaps perhaps a bit longer than i
thought so should i stop sharing now or
i'm thinking that maybe people hello uh
there might be so
i will open up for for questions
uh maybe keep the sharing in case people
want to ask about the
okay guys i just yeah i certainly have a
few questions so if if you're doing
multi-objective
optimization so this is a very basic
question like what what what is it that
you get back like what does a
solution look like or do you like it a
bunch of solutions that is somehow
describing you know some kind of what's
it called pareto frontier
or like what you get well the the the
built in
the built-in multi-objective
optimization
replaces the multi-lexicographic
optimization
so you can have several of the objective
functions that are
ordered by a priority level by priority
levels
right and so what you then get is
is in this case is is the the when
when when the when it runs through is
the model that is
uh optim is one model or all models
depending on what you want
that is optimum with respect to to to
this
lexicographic ordering of objective
functions
if you use the the the aspirin
system that we developed where you can
actually use pareto and all that
type of thingy you will get several ones
or actually you would get
no no i think it's the same thing if you
just ask for one you get one
pareto optimal if you want all you get
all of them which is hard enough
or if you want five you get five or
whatever
so in an asp solver you always if you
say nothing you also only get one model
but if you if you give it a zero you get
all and if you otherwise give a number
you get the number you
you want
okay um then
i was wondering like what's the
as i understand it you're it seems like
you can
extend asp you can sort of i mean
it seemed like you can sort of do smt
but based on
asp rather than somehow boolean
satisfiability and it seemed that you
know so it's kind of a base language
that you can extend in
many different directions was the
impression i got so
what like the what's like the the killer
reason why i would want to use asp
rather than you know starting with say
sat or starting with mixed integer
linear programming or
again if if it's just on the esp set
or milk i think it's really the modeling
language and the grounder that comes
with it
that you get very quickly the thing is
typical example is
when we either work with other academics
or with a company on something
they bring a toy example we sit together
normally in the lab right
then we discuss it and normally the idea
where i asked them before bring a toy
example that of your application
that we can resolve with paper and
pencil and after one or two hours we
have this model
and then that's also a stereotypical
thing that always happens then
we push then the guys are very excited
about this we push
the button and well what always happens
is they say
oh no but that's wrong um
and then well silence and then i asked
oh
what's wrong and they explained and said
well you didn't tell us about that let's
just
form let's look let's just add at this
these constraints and then you do this a
couple of times and then one is
they go out with the first model of the
application right and i think this
nicely shows actually what the benefit
of this modeling language
rapid prototyping really transparency
and i think this is really what makes it
different what makes a difference
so rather than like you're saying that
if i write my problem as a cnf formula
then it's very hard to know what i've
written or
even like an integer linear programming
is not clear but somehow it's more
intuitive
so so it's easier to parse like to make
the mapping from reality to
well there are two things one thing is
um norm
one thing is you you as far as i know
right there may be things now around
there there is no modeling language for
for sat problems there are some i know
there was the
the guys at mit for software engineering
or whatever but the thing is
and and valentin
so anyway so you you you do not want to
sit down
and write your problem in dynamics
that's the provocative answer
right no answer
yeah and and and asp actually allows you
to
actually if you if you want to don't
even take don't even take the don't even
take
class as the solver right but you can
you can write
it in asp's modeling language
declare all the variables as choices and
then you
you let yourself output dynamics and
give it to a set solver but then you can
start modeling
on on a higher level
right so i'm i'm not saying that writing
down uh necessarily um
rules is is definitely what you
absolutely want i find it intuitive but
you know i grew up with this so
but at least having this modeling
language is a big asset
and then but but then on the other you
could say okay if we're doing
some kind of first order is logic anyway
then why not do first order logic and i
don't know run the vampire or whatever
but
then maybe like the point is with asp
you have a somehow
a nice enough subset that you you you
get better performance or better if you
well the thing is the thing is um
i think this question has been answered
by the sub community right
because i think until i don't know
i i happened to be at the ekkai where
where bart and henry
presented um presented uh their paper on
solving planning problems with with
with sat right that was big breakthrough
and at the until then
the world was dominated by fear
improvements
but then actually my impression is that
that theory improving is almost
non-existing
and set solving is the basic technology
when it comes to
to to solving um logical application
problems
and and this is you know this this
display between first order and and
first order and uh and and and and and
logic and set right uh they they already
sorted that out so asp actually what asp
adds
uh is is because at the end of the day
it's a
it's a propositional solving approach
right it takes it it relies on the same
benefits that that such solving
technology
relies on because if you would go back
to unification and
and and and all that i think you would
lose a lot of speed and
i don't think there's any there's any
anything to be gained
to suddenly look at at the first order
asp theorem
that's a bit of of a nuisance that we
i can't see your faces now
[Laughter]
yeah yeah so i don't see if there
there's one comment in the chat that i'm
debating with myself
whether i will be able to
read the doctor whether i should just
ask mata to
speak i don't know you can try mata do
you want to
say your comment or you want me to read
it for you you should be able to speak
now
[Music]
uh yes yeah
hi yeah i know i i just wanted to note
that
i guess some people are uh using slash
abusing the smp lib um
quantifier three bit vector um
[Music]
logic as a sort of a modeling language
i'm not saying it's great i'm just
saying that that's
you know that does happen and i've seen
people using z3 for example to
to do that and then ask you know z3 to
uh
output an smt lib i mean by a python and
then you know like grind it down with
like let's say
stp into a cnf and then you know eat
that
i mean it's not great because you don't
know the exact mapping you know once all
this grinding has happened
um i think and and there are some other
specific
uh uh modeling languages like enf which
is specific to a field like in that case
cryptography
and there are a few now i mean sagemath
for example has an enf to cnf converter
i mean i'm not saying this is great i it
has like it doesn't even touch
you know what you have done uh in terms
of complexity being able to debug i know
that your system also has that
but i just wanted to say that there are
some like sort of attempts but i don't
think
it's as comprehensive and as sort of
like well done
and integrated as as is what you have
presented here
well thank you but
then here and mccreesh also had the
comment that the
the again constraint programming there's
a mini zinc that can be turned into cnf
but not
necessarily in a good way but i guess
yeah so the point is that that somehow
if you're doing sat solving i think it's
clear that there is some layer i mean
you're probably
you're not writing your problem in dimex
right you're writing your problem
somewhere else and then there's a dimex
generator somehow probably right
so yeah
so i
um so i have one more question
i don't see any other questions so i
guess i'll ask it so
what about uh correctness or
you know if i want to certify that the
the answer of
class for clingo is is correct or
optimal or
like what what does that community would
call proof logging
yeah yeah yeah um actually there was
some work to do this
uh for asp as well by johannes fischter
and marcus hescher
but it's not something that is has found
more
informative in the mainstream there are
a couple of things for instance i'm now
shifting a bit the attention because
there i can better explain it right
where it's really hard to to to follow
follow certain functionalities if you
want to count models
it's so one can do this for instance for
a very simple fragment like just normal
roots but once you have all the
aggregates and this language
these language it gets really difficult
and you really have to
put a lot of effort into that and i
think for the proof
this is more or less the same thing
right as long as you just stay with
normal rules that should all be fine
but once you have once you have um
these these other language constructs um
it's it's it's not obvious how
how how you do that
and hence all these things do not i'm
not really getting addressed because
um our in our community there is a much
smaller percentage of people doing
implementation than compared to the sad
community
i see i i note that
johannes and marcus i think are both
among the attendees i don't know if you
want to comment on
proof logging aspects or
[Music]
otherwise i think
[Music]
i don't see any other questions
good and i can stop sharing so
i'll just uh on behalf of all the
listeners
thanking i would like to thank you for a
great talk very interesting
thank you and uh and for pointing us to
resources where we can learn
more about asp
yeah as i said um at potasco.org you
find a lot of resources and you can
check it out and
and cooldip is reminding
us okay do i have the link somewhere do
you have the link somewhere cool deep um
there's a
for for people attending the workshop
there's a gather town link
if people want to hang out which is now
being posted in the chat
so please do feel free to join there
and next week next tuesday we're having
another overviewish tutorial-ish talk
which will be on
maximum satisfiability or max at solving
so i'm looking forward to seeing you
then but
this is all for today thank you so much
okay thank you
bye